[Musique]
comment as-tu pu laisser le morveux de Beltasar s'en
tirer tu es viré
il est en train de jongler dans ce jongler admettre
qu'est-ce que tu fais si tu n'as pas de
fille je voulais juste ton aide
ah excuse moi hé bien yo
oh  bien sûr non je disais salut bon mon
sérieux Wow je dois vraiment avoir un mot
avec toi au nom de ton frère jumeau a
dessiné ce que nous frère hé frère
j'ai hâte de rencontrer Michael
[Music]
n'aime pas le regard de ce gars
eux ici vous rendraient meilleur tellement en colère que
vous pourriez être la belle vie beau
parleur cet endroit est incroyable enflammez mon
Dieu je ne suis pas vraiment intéressant
la méchanceté de base est dans votre sang hé
vous cherchez des insectes prêt à continuer la
tradition familiale  toi et moi non j'ai laissé
cette vie derrière moi juste une nuit
j'y vais d'accord
est ce que ça veut dire qu'ils redeviennent
méchants ha ha ha ha
ouais
alors je peux monter d'un cran
[Musique]
Yoshida  Poisson hey sis je ne
m'éloigne pas du zeppole à Yokosuka émissions
du roboticl  e synagogue ce
bâtard êtes-vous deux jumeaux sont si similaires
vous imaginez une petite petite boutique dans un
bus attendez je ne sais pas ce qui
arrive Jim exactement pensez-vous
que vous pensez que Louise il connaît le pas de jacuzzi ha
ha allons-nous jouer m'emprunter certains de  sur
[Musique]
mr.  Horloge Schad Kiki Hey
boo hoo ha rit de bon cœur oh yeah got
it
[Musique]
joyeux anniversaire Dan happy bird
[Applaudissements]